the Game of Thrones stars are finally
able to speak out about how does
blockbuster fantasy series came to a
close and whilst some are happy with
their endings others particularly the
mother of dragons seem to be less than
thrilled throughout sir run on Thrones
Emilia Clarke has taken Daenerys
Targaryen from a naive frightened child
bride to a formidable and lethal dragon
queen but underneath it all
Daenerys is thought to juggle her desire
for justice with her genetic makeup
after all she is a daughter of the
infamous Mad King Aerys Targaryen
even so audiences have always rooted for
tenaris cheering Arana she frees slaves
saves innocents and fights those in
power to give it to those below until
the end of season eight the Narus is
torching of King's Landing during the
penultimate episode the bowels wasn't
entirely unexpected but her descended
the madness for seniors abrupt and
unearned as if viewers were supposed to
forget about the nurses humanity and
believed she would kill thousands of
innocent people without a passing
thought for her part Clarke might have
tried to warn audiences about this
before the season aired in 2018 Clarke
revealed to Vanity Fair that her final
scenes are incredibly upsetting and that
fans might look at the Narus differently
given us her continued passion for war
Lisa Jon Snow ultimately having to kill
her during an Emmys events before the
final season premiered it's hard to
overlook her facial expression other
actors have expressed some frustrations
about the final season - they include
one of the most compelling infuriating
evil and dynamic characters on Game of
Thrones is Cersei Lannister thanks in no
small part to the performance of Lena
Headey even as Cersei committed
unspeakable atrocities killing anyone in
destroying everything in a path to make
sure the Lannister stayed in power funds
were occasionally swayed thanks to the
heart and depth he be put into Circe's
character fans expected attending for
Cersei that was a sensationalist hedis
performance unfortunately Circe's grand
exit didn't pan out his plan both fans
were mulling over theories that range
from everything from death by Jamie's
golden hand to Arya or the Hound killing
Cersei they were ultimately given a
sequence in which Cersei and twin
brother Jaime are crushed by bricks in
each other's arms and the bottom of the
red keep
even he D was annoyed at this closing
scene saying she wanted something bigger
or any sorts of fights at all as freed
slave Masson de Natalie a manual brought
a considerable amount of heart to an
often cruel show fans
after friendship with Daenerys as well
as her relationship with grey worm the
leader of the unsullied army but grew
apprehensive when Musante and grey worm
started to make plans for the future
always a bad sign assan they ended up
captured by Circe's forces and was
beheaded in front of Daenerys in a show
of cruelty and power after the episode
Emanuel said that it was disappointing
to see the shows one woman of color
killed so abruptly she also spoke to the
emotional weight of Musante dying in
Chains which brought her full circle and
the most heartbreaking way possible fans
and critics agreed with Emanuel and it
seems as no shortage of viewers who
think there should have been more
justice for the character one of the
most mysterious and interesting
characters and Thrones Lord Varys played
by Conliffe pale seemed to their every
secret in all of Westeros though Varys
began the series firmly in the Lannister
camp he eventually switched sides to his
friend Tyrion Lannister and Daenerys
escort's having known Daenerys dangerous
father he remained cautious after Masson
day's execution he concocted a plan to
tell the Seven Kingdoms about the true
heir to the throne Jon Snow only to be
found out and burned alive at the
narrator's order after varus's death he
told Entertainment Weekly that he was
upset by the last couple of seasons he
was disappointed that the showrunners
couldn't devise a final meeting between
Varys and Littlefinger considering that
the two characters often work together
to pull the strings he added that he
wasn't sure the series successfully
moved past author George RR Martin's
source material
with the outcome of the shot first layer
by season AE to tyrion lanister had been
Daenerys s top advisor for quite some
time
but in her eyes had begun to falter
between underestimate sing a sinister
sister Circe and being too trusting of
his brother Jamie relations between the
dragon queen in her hands were
splintering actor Peter Dinklage
certainly has a good relationship with
his character but he also made not so
subtle hints at his frustration with how
the show ended in a video about the end
of the show he criticized the decision
to put all the women and children in a
crypt full of the dead during the Battle
of Winterfell the most telling moments
come to an entertainment asked how he
felt about the ending there are no
better writers in television and dan
Wesson David Benioff you people are in
for it
some fans described the interview as a
quote hostage video check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you